last I checked it was a massively
successful company and I was like how
are you getting all this private company
daily he's like oh it's just like did
you know that in Australia in many of
the countries in Europe if you're a
privately held company that's above like
40 million in revenue I think you have
to submit an annual report yes I didn't
know that I've went to the Australia's
version and the British I'll show you
this version it cost $5 per report
it's called Companies House for Britain
it's completely free I just like looked
up all these cool companies and you can
see how much like dividends they make
right if my friend started this in in
Great Britain also called due diligence
this is called do deal is his company
and I think it's like a massively last I
checked it was like a massively
successful company and I was like how
are you getting all this private company
data he's like oh it's just like you
have to make it available here so what
we do is we just aggregate it present it
make it searchable and I was like oh my
god like you know Jesus how you know hey
I wish that existed in the US and B what
a simple beautiful business to do I'm
looking at the amazing did you find
anything interesting from these or to
just want to shout them at his cool tool
so what was the one I'm gonna check out
the Australian when it was what house
company house that's Britain it's free I
don't know what it was just easy to use
like am i I know it's not Companies
House is easy to use the Australian one
it's not easy it was called the
Australian AAS I see Australian
Securities and Investment Commission I
guess that's their equivalent up the SEC
right and it cost money so I looked up a
research business that was similar to
mine and I was curious and the founder
just pays himself ten million dollars a
year and it's in there I just looked at
the financials it's pretty big
it's called them you probably know this
Ibis world yeah yeah yeah it was well I
didn't realize that's so you know idea
is and these might this might exist
already but you can build a layer on top
of these just to make them more
user-friendly
searchable it's sort of easy to use
clean up the data in some way and those
can be pretty pretty awesome businesses
import genius is a great example of this
you know publicly available customs data
that they make a it's not even that easy
to use but they make an interface that
makes it very sort of simple and easy to
find the data that you're looking for
and so you know if there's some
entrepreneur in Australia who wants to
take ASIC and make it more of a consumer
facing website or maybe that exists but
that would be a cool opportunity
[Music]